je m'appelle bac j'ai été désigné pour
m'occuper de vous et je ne cache pas la
grande joie est immense fierté que j'ai
à vous recevoir
[Musique]
je vais vous laisser travailler ça une
petite heure
une affaire urgente à régler en ville
évidemment ça quand je reviens c'est par
coeur
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez compris le système
de l'orgue à peu près un mois donc je
vous le rappelle en deux mots les
soufflets sont actionnés afin que l'air
soit envoyé à l'intérieur des tuyaux
afin que ça fasse tutut mais les
corréziens
ou alors ne soyez pas ne soyez pas ne
soyez pas
vous savez que les danses et 32
normalement c'est pas tes pas ça qui a
été choisi son nom dedans comme cela
arrange ça je n'ai écrit pour que ce
soit joué comme ça
[Musique]
un tag le guen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh ben